you see the uh guy sitting behind gary
on camera yes who is that
that's uh antonio pierce he's on the new
york giants he's he's our intern
what yeah he wants to get into
broadcasting he's interning
for the day hey maybe antonio can teach
sal and jason how to throw a ball
jason i heard bad things about in terms
of every sport
howard if you watch the two of them you
should have antonio watch them throw a
ball
and just critique it live on there all
right get them in here you got a
football
always always there's always a football
in this office and let antonio watch uh
jason throw the football
and sell too all right antonio one of
your tasks today
is to watch oh there's our coffees
thank you watch jason throw a football
see if you can teach him all right throw
to gary hold on wait a second
let me see he's not serious
no he's serious
go ahead
[Laughter]
what's he doing wrong
everything all right throw it one more
time try over your shoulder
over over yeah yeah this is it
over the show that's not that's
something that's better that's better
that's improved
thank you my mo what my father never did
for me thank you
thank you antonio that was good all
right next client
all right so you're doing uh is your
friend
go ahead show him how you throw and then
maybe he can correct you
go ahead
[Laughter]
okay antonio what do you make of that
throat that is a shot put
that's track and field show them again
show antonio what you're doing
so you can get a feel of what you're up
to
let's try over do the same thing what
did you do just just roll your shoulder
just try doing this a couple times
just get the motion down you know just
do a couple of days yeah
and now just without the ball just go
like this you know take the ball out
take the ball out of here take the ball
off your hand and just let's do some
shoulder rotations let's just loosen up
some shoulders
something yeah yeah that might be a bad
shoulder all right now pick up the ball
okay over the shoulder now over the
shoulder flick the wrist the same motion
okay all right just flick the mission
all right it's a little bit
whatever i do i'll throw it towards
robin all right
oh yeah that was horrible can you teach
a guy like him to throw or is it
impossible
some guys just don't have no athletic
ability yeah and i think he's one of
them
yeah just give the ball about your ear
right around your ear right around
your ear yeah and throw there you go
all right get out of here you're
hopeless